we're asked to solve for X and we have
this compound inequality here negative
16 is less than or equal to 3x plus 5
which is less than or equal to 20 and
really there's two ways to approach it
which are really the same way and I'll
do both of them and I'll actually do
both of them simultaneously so one is to
just solve this compound inequality all
at once and I'll just rewrite it
negative 16 is less than or equal to 3x
plus 5 which is less than or equal to 20
and the other way is to think of it as
two separate inequalities but both of
them need to be true so you could also
view it as negative 16 has to be less
than or equal to 3x plus 5 and and 3x +
5 3x plus five needs to be less than or
equal to 20 this statement and this
statement are equivalent this one might
seem a little bit more familiar because
we can independently solve each of these
inequalities and just remember the and
this one might seem a little less
traditional because now we have three
sides to the statement we have three
parts of this compound inequality but we
can see is it we're actually going to
solve it the exact same way in any
situation we really just want to isolate
the X on one side of the inequality or
in this case one part of the compound
inequality well the best way to isolate
this X right here is to first get rid of
this positive five that's sitting in the
middle so let's subtract five from every
part of this compound inequality so I'm
going to subtract five there subtract
five there and subtract five over there
and so we get 16 negative 16 minus five
is negative 21 is less than or equal to
3x plus five minus five is three X which
is less than or equal to 20 minus 5
which is 15 and we could essentially do
the same thing here if we want to
isolate the 3x we can subtract five from
both sides subtract five from both sides
we get negative 21 and negative 21 is
less than or equal to 3x + and we get
subtracting 5 from both sides and notice
we're just subtracting 5 from every part
of this compound inequality we get 3x is
less than or equal to 15 so this
statement in this statement once again
are the exact same thing now going back
here if we want to isolate the
X we can divide by three we have to do
two every part of the inequality and
since three is positive we don't have to
change the sign so let's divide every
part of this compound inequality by
three you divide every part by three
this is equivalent to dividing every
part of each of these inequalities every
part of these inequalities by three and
then we get negative twenty-one divided
by three is negative seven is less than
or equal to X which is less than or
equal to 15 divided by 3 is 5 you do it
here you get negative seven is less than
or equal to X and and X is less than or
equal to 15 over 3 which is 5 this
statement and this statement are
completely equal and we've solved for X
we've given you the solution set and if
we want to graph it on a number line if
we want to graph it on a number line it
would look like this it would look like
this is 0 this is 5 this is negative 7
our solution set it includes everything
between negative at 7 and 5 including
negative 7 and 5 so we'll have solid it
we have to fill in the circles on
negative 7 and positive 5 and it is
everything in between
that's our solution set and so we can
verify that these works you could try
out a number that's well inside of our
solution set like 0 3 times 0 is 0 so
you're just left with 5 is greater than
or equal to negative 16 which is true
and 5 is less than or equal to 20 or
negative 16 is less than or equal to 5
which is less than or equal to 20 so
that works that makes sense
you could try 5 if you put 5 here you
get 3 times 5 plus 5 well that's just 20
negative 16 is less than or equal to 20
which is less than or equal to 20 that
works negative 7 should also work 3
times negative 7 is negative 21 plus 5
is negative 16 so you get negative 16
which is less than or equal to negative
16 which is less than or equal to 20 and
you could try other values you could go
outside of our solution set try
something like 10 10 should not work and
if you see here if you put 10 here you
get 3 times 10 plus 5 is 35 35 negative
16 is less than or equal to 35 but 35 is
not less than or equal to 20 and that's
why 10 is not part of our
lucien set